zu den mutationen das robert koch
institut hat mit den laboren erneut eine
repräsentative stichprobe von über
23.000 positiven pcr test analysiert
sowie zusätzlich genomsequenz daten
ausgewertet
die daten zeigen dass sich die mutation
auch in deutschland stark ausbreiten
besonders die virusvariante die das
erste mal im vereinigten königreich
entdeckt worden ist bereitet uns sorge
vor zwei wochen machte diese variante
noch einen anteil von knapp sechs
prozent der untersuchten proben aus
inzwischen sind es über 20 über 22
prozent
das heißt wie auch schon in anderen
ländern beobachtet verdoppelt sich der
anteil der infektion mit dieser
virusvariante ungefähr jede woche wir
müssen damit rechnen dass die variante
bald auch bei uns die dominierende
werden könnte
der anteil der südafrikanischen variante
liest auf deutlich niedrigerem niveau
bei etwa eineinhalb prozent das robert
koch institut wird in einem bericht die
details im laufe des tages die werden
jetzt noch final zusammengeführt
veröffentlichen und der professor villa
wird mit mir auch am freitag in der
bundespressekonferenz dazu ein weiteres
mal rede und antwort stehen
ermutigend an diesen nachrichten in der
lage heute ist gleichzeitig dass die
infektionszahlen sinken
obwohl sich diese virusvariante in
deutschland weiter ausbreitet stecken
sich aktuell jedenfalls weniger menschen
an
bei uns in deutschland mit dem corona
virus das bedeutet unsere
schutzmaßnahmen wirken
das sollte und muss nur nun auch so
bleiben
das bedeutet deswegen auch wir müssen
mit blick auf die mutationen sehr
vorsichtig sein wenn wir jetzt langsam
den lockdown verlassen
zuerst einmal ist es ja finde ich bis
hierhin
stand heute mittag ermutigend dass
obwohl wir etwa eine verdreifachung
hatten mehr als verdreifachen hatten so
muss ich ja sagen fast eine verdopplung
jede woche in den letzten zwei wochen
vor drei wochen die wir überblick haben
das obwohl der anteil so stark gestiegen
ist die zahlen trotzdem gesunken sind
die infektionszahlen mit der vermutung
nah dass die variante den vereinigten
königreich zuerst entdeckt wurde
anstecken da ist und das zeigt ja dass
maßnahmen auch die maßnahmen die
ergriffen sind zur kontakt reduzierung
wirken und einen unterschied machen
können und die schlussfolgerung ist für
mich dass wir die wege die wir jetzt
gehen eben mit ganz besonderer vorsicht
gehen müssen und bei jedem schritt den
wir gehen das wird jetzt auch begonnen
in vielen bundesländern bei kitas und
schulen was ich es richtig finde dass
dort zuerst begonnen wird auch wieder
unter pandemie bedingungen mit
bestimmten konzepten an vielen stellen
aber eben auch wieder mit präsenz und
ich finde wir müssen jetzt wirklich
einfach jeden tag schauen was macht das
etwas verändert dass in der dynamik und
dann wirklich nach mal dauerte immer ein
paar tage bis man das wirklich sehen
kann dann immer noch ein zwei wochen
schauen wo stehen wir gerade
aber man kann ich habe ja nichts gegen
pläne die sich an incidents werten oder
oder anderen parametern festmachen
sozusagen in der abfolge aber eins ist
schon wichtig dass wir immer wieder
miteinander so schwer das feld und so
sehr wir alle planbarkeit wollen mit
diesem neuen thema nämlich der mutation
und der möglicherweise höheren
ansteckungsfähigkeit wirklich alle 12
wochen schauen wo wir stehen
beim weg raus aus dem block ermutigen
bleibt aber wie gesagt die letzten zwei
drei wochen kontakt reduzierung helfen
offenkundig auch bei den mutationen und
damit
um damit einmal mehr zu enden aber aus
vom aus voller überzeugung nicht einfach
nur uns noch einmal gesagt zu haben
damit bleibt es übrigens bei einem punkt
unbedingt wir machen den unterschied
jeder jeden tag dieses virus kommt
alleine keine zehn zentimeter weit durch
den raum
es kommt nur durch uns weiter das gilt
für notierte wären genauso mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren